joining us now is a former chairman of
the senate judiciary committee and the
senior senator from the great state of
south carolina
lindsey graham senator you and i talk
about the justice system all the time
there are parts that should be reformed
but setting bond for career offenders
who absconded from the sex offender
registry would not be what we're talking
about now
and number one what does it take to lose
your license in wisconsin was this guy
driving legally i mean there's so many
things to talk about here but you know
you did a really good job of making this
case real what do you say to the family
of the victims
how do we go to them as a nation and
explain to them that this man was
allowed to be loose
given his criminal record
the chickens are coming home to roost
when it comes to crime and the radical
left it is fashionable in blue states
and liberal districts to be soft on
crime it is not fashionable among the
average american to allow this to go on
and on and on so we need to vote to
leave
congresswoman to leave has a bill to
empty all the federal prisons by 10
years
mass incarceration needs to go
regardless of apparently what you did
because of covet and
the some squad members want to do a cash
bill let's vote on this let's take this
issue to the house and the senate and
see where members of congress and the
senate would vote i'm going to stand
with the cops i'm going to stand with
making
it harder to get bail when you maul
people over and over not easier
i want to play a clip for you senator
i'm going to get your reaction on the
other side
when they read out all of the charges
that he had prior to what he did on
sunday
it made me sick to my stomach and then
to hear him start crying when the judge
mentioned that these carried a life
sentence
to me it was selfish that he did that
that he was worried about himself
you know senator you mentioned members
of the squad of bond reform you
mentioned uh rashida talib
you you you know as much about the
federal prison system i mean
think about who is in federal prison
that she wants out in a decade i mean
the boston marathon bomber the unabomber
terry nichols for people who forgot who
terry nichols is in oklahoma city
and then on her own state of south
carolina i'm almost positive dylan rufus
on death row is he not
yeah i mean betray that this is insane
and crazy and dangerous 2022 is going to
be a very dangerous year for america if
something doesn't change terrorism is on
the rise we have rampant inflation if we
pass bill back better it's just going to
throw gasoline on our inflation problem
we have a broken border you've got iran
about to break out with their nuclear
program putting israel in a box and here
at home you've got all these crazy
people pushing laws that make it harder
to prosecute people to let people out
who should be in jail and
look at what's happening throughout
california where people are going into
stores and cleaning out the place you
know thousands of dollars are being
taken by these flash mobs and whatever
happens to them this started with
defunding the police this concept of
defunding the police has sent a signal
to criminals that they're no more
consequences when it comes to breaking
the law and people are not afraid of
breaking the law anymore people are
emboldened to break the law so in south
carolina where we live you cry you try
this crap here you're going to go to
jail if you're lucky
you say it's uh going to be on the
ballot in november um
yeah i hope that republicans can
quit fighting with one another long and
i mean this is a great issue this is a
this is a fantastic issue if we can
focus on that instead of the other
nonsense
amen trey i mean listen we're the party
of
having the cops back i'm i'm all for
judicial reform i'm all for police
reform but i'm not for letting this guy
out of jail when he should have been in
jail years ago i'm not for letting
people ransack uh you know stores and
have no accountability i'm not for doing
a cash bail you know the modern
democratic party is soft on crime and
weak on terrorism and if we're if we as
republicans don't talk about that then
that's political malpractice the
democratic party is giving us an issue
where the american people are on our
side the enemy is not federal of federal
republicans the enemy is the radical
left who's driving the democratic party
down an insane road making this less
safe and less prosperous and we need to
push back and if we win in 2022 all this
crap stops kevin mccarthy never lets
these bills come out of the house and i
can assure you if i'm chairman of the
judiciary committee or any other
republican as chairman of the judiciary
committee we're going to have hearings
about how you can loot a store and
nothing happens to you we're going to
have hearings about how a state can let
a guy like this out after all of his
criminal record and why you would set
bail at a thousand dollars
thousand dollar bond it's hard to
believe senator i do hope you uh and
your family had a good thanksgiving i
look forward to seeing you in person
soon thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else